and we back live
yes
let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back live and full effect I
got so much going on I gotta get you
caught up on House of dragons
She-Hulk the hauntingly crazy series
Dahmer Antonio Brown's dick is out
um what else Kanye West White lives
matter so much going on and I just
haven't done a lot but so he's back
everybody
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back to riffing
with Griffin and we are alive
we are live
with it with Griffin live in full effect
all right and this episode is brought to
you by doordash doordash for a limited
time our listeners get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app enter code Griffin don't forget
that's code Griffin for a 25 percent off
your first order with door Jazz subjects
to change terms apply Russell brought to
you by Helix sleep Helix sleep
hello have you had your mattress maybe
it's time to get a new mattress because
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free panels
pillows for our listeners go to Helix
sleep.com slash Griffin with Helix
better sleep starts now
all right y'all welcome back to riffia
with Griffin
welcome back to Riverwood Griffin oh and
let me do some other business for me let
me do my business uh everybody this
weekend if you're in the Ontario area
Ontario every people I'm coming to The
Improv Ontario Improv October 7th
through the 9th get there
if you and Cali you in the San
Bernardino area come get you some
riffing with Griffin comedy live I'll
see you there
[Music]
all right
um yeah so uh
anyways
um yeah so we're here we're here live
guys uh what's been going on a lot's
been going on you know I went to the
doctor you know and I got I gotta work
on my stuff man I've been kind of
slipping last few months since the
wedding actually since after the wedding
you're going on the honeymoon I haven't
been doing my stuff regularly so I
started up again because I went to the
doctor cholesterol is a little too high
blood sugar is like getting to that
pre-diabetic range
so I have to work on these things so
like
I'm back to it and I was eating like
desserts and stuff I mean I felt like a
fat ass like the other day I was at the
comedy store and they got this great
restaurant across the street
um at the pantry hotel to get this great
restaurant at the bottom of and they got
all these great desserts so I went and
got this like you know delicious ass
dessert and I'm sitting in the back of
the condom you start eating and then
Frank Castillo funny comic comes by and
he's like what are you doing man looks
like you're cheating and it did because
I'm like in the back dark eating a
dessert like a you know and I got like
I'm not supposed to be doing this and I
wasn't so I know I've been eating like
bad in the past like few months and
that's affected my health so I'm back on
it I'm not eating a lot of extra sweets
at all the sweetest thing I'm gonna have
is like coffee I like coffee I honey in
my coffee that's it I like honey in my
coffee but I'm not trying to get any
extra sugars I mean that's the thing you
know a lot of things have sugar in it
you eat rice you eat like there's some
things that are sort of like natural uh
things that have sugar uh you know you
have some barbecue sauce if you have a
barbecue I mean it's like there's so
many things like that
I'm trying not to have like I don't
really need sweets I'm not a sweet Sky
I'm not really a big dessert guy you
know and it's like I just got to keep
all that stuff away from me I don't need
to be eating a bag of Oreos and all that
kind of stuff so I am working on my
health
um again I mean I was and then I just
tapered off a little bit it's so easy
you know
I mean it's like I like I am perfectly
suited to talk about
fat people okay because for the most
part I know what it is is straight up
laziness it's two things
eating good food is feels good eating
sweets and all the things that you're
not supposed to eat it's so easy to do
that it makes you feel good there's like
something that happens in our brains
where we're like God damn this honey bun
tastes good and also
exercising and doing the things no
matter how small the effort is like
they're not even asking you to do a big
big thing and like you know when we
think of working out we think like oh I
have to be like you know Mr Universe on
a damn uh you know uh you know treadmill
or not or like in a weight room and
stuff like that and it's not really what
it is
at my age you just need like 20 30
minutes of solid Activity three four
times a week and it's so easy to do I
had this rowing machine I really love
doing it I always feel good when I
finish eat when I finish doing it but
just that process of making myself say
go on a walk or do some activities
the reason why I'm not doing that is
straight up laziness it's just straight
up making a choice of being like making
excuses that's what it is I'm speaking
from experience this is my experience
and if you a fat ass out there and you
can relate then just give me a shout out
being like I know what you mean but all
these people who are like on this body
positivity train trying to make people
like myself feel bad like oh you're not
supposed to say that I'm saying the god
honest truth all right I'm speaking my
truth
it's lazy decisions it's like convincing
yourself like ah I do this later or I'll
do it another time or it's like not make
it's bad habits bad eating habits bad
exercise habits and it doesn't take that
long or that much of a great effort like
if you're trying to get in shape to run
a marathon that's a whole different
thing but if you're just trying to live
a healthy life keep your cholesterol
down keep your blood sugar down keep
your inflammation down keep all the
things that lead to heart attack
dementia heart uh you know um Cancer all
these kinds of things I think that it's
like the amount of effort that it takes
to help
keep those things at Bay
it's worth it Okay so
I'm asking my Roofing with Griffin
Community keep me accountable man
keep asking me about it in the comments
yo Griff you working out you know hey
man you uh make sure you know you know
hey I think I saw I saw you at a
restaurant I don't think you should have
had that dessert keep me accountable
y'all help me stay alive I'm trying to
have kids and you know
I'm you know it's like I'm working on it
It's just tough you know what I mean uh
it's like and I was anyways I don't want
to get too personal into my business but
you know anyways I'm working on it
vitamins
vitamin D B12 other things that we're
deficient in that we don't even realize
I'm working on all that stuff at the
same time you know
trying to live
a long life y'all just trying to live a
long life
so you out there you can help me out and
I'll help you out we could talk about it
together
all right I got a bunch of stuff to talk
about today I mean I want to do some
reviews I want to get caught up because
I've been doing great episodes with
Rachel and Rachel and I are still going
to do stuff together and I might move a
lot of that over to patreon so please if
you uh want to be you know again excuse
me thank you for being here at riffin
with Griffin oh see I didn't even I
needed to change that I didn't
excuse me I just drank some water it's
messing me up all right
subscribe share get hit the
notifications button please
I'm on Twitch daily check me out there
y'all and then like I say I might do
regular episodes now with Rachel uh
uh you know and that's on patreon if you
want to support and by the way
you can either you can either be a
patreon member you could be a twitch
subscriber
because you'll get that content there or
YouTube member any one of those three
I'm putting the videos there so you can
pick one you don't have to do all three
you could pick one of those and that's
where the bonus content is gonna go
because I have fun with Rachel with the
Iron Man review I don't know if you guys
saw that but you gotta check that out so
I'm gonna what we're gonna I'm gonna
have her do is we're gonna watch so we
watch Iron Man so we're gonna watch the
first door we're gonna watch the first
Captain America
okay
um what's another one that has a solo
movie we might watch one of the like
Civil War one of those maybe even black
panther because she was like really
wanted to see that and then we're gonna
watch Avengers then after Avengers we're
gonna skip all that stuff and then we're
gonna go right to uh infinity war and
end game and we're gonna get Rachel's
Rachel's review which was uh funny so
anyways let's just get into some stuff
that's going on in the news that I
wanted to talk about that I thought was
kind of silly some of this stuff is
silly so one of the things is Kanye West
man Kanye West was seen uh with Candace
Owens who was a conservative black
conservative pundit uh you know she's
out there with her things and she's out
there uh they're out here wearing a
white lives matter
you know t-shirts
hey and then like Will Smith's son Jaden
Smith was just going in on the internet
about it you know he was tweeting at the
storm we demand a more Progressive
future black lives matter I don't care
who it is I don't feel the message I'm
out the leader should lead you know you
know it's like I don't know man I think
Kanye is basically trolling everybody
both sides
this is my feeling on it like if it was
anyone else
if it was anyone else maybe I would feel
some outrage as a person of color you
know but like at this point I had to
take the messenger I have to take in
account who the messenger is and this
guy got all his business out on the
street text messages from his wife you
know his mother and ex-mother-in-law all
the stuff he got on the internet about
like what he's trying to do with his
kids uh putting all his like uh business
stuff on blast like you know messages
from Reebok or whatever the the business
with his company and these other
companies so he's just out here on the
internet and using it as a way of some
sort of weird negotiations now Kanye has
some kind of like serious issue with
black the black lives matter movement
the people that were in charge of it he
has whatever his issues he's has about
it but I'm taking this with like a ah
this is some Kanye stuff I'm not taking
it too serious I'm not I'm not I don't
care about this I think he's trolling
both sides you know because I think that
he's trolling the side that like like
that but really are like yeah white
lives matter good for you Kanye I'm
gonna buy your shoes I think he's
trolling them and then I think he's
trolling the black community because you
know it's so wishy-washy when they
support it when they don't support that
I think he's trolling them and I think
he's trolling everybody man I think the
dude is a master manipulator I think he
knows how to use social media and uh
publicity is every like what's that
saying any publicity is good publicity I
think he's just doing that
you know I don't always like to message
but I have to take into account the
messenger and I think Kanye it's like
all right you know what I mean like to
be all worked up and offended now he got
people with blue check marks talking
about him they got people like I got a
blue check mark and I'm on the internet
on my podcast talking about him so I
think that it's just I think it just is
what it is I think Kanye is a super
troll I think he's a super Troll And I
think that you know we just have to be
we just have to be like all right Kanye
doing Kanye stuff again and just kind of
let it go you know that's my feeling
about it I don't know what you guys feel
uh if you want to in the comments and I
always um I'm always up for some good
respectful comments man some discourse
so you know if you are anti-kanye put
your point out I'll respond if it's but
like like I always say don't start with
like you're an idiot if you stop out
like that I'm out I'm hiding you from my
channel and I'm moving on with my life
that's just my new [ __ ] even on Twitter
and Instagram somebody's tweeted
something stupid at me I just mute you
you get one chance honestly you get one
chance you send me something out of
pocket I mute you you send me something
out of pocket on Instagram I restrict
you I never see it again if you know
what restrict is it comes up in your
thing and it says restricted account I
just delete it I spend I just that's all
I do I just go edit find the restricted
ones delete and I never I don't care if
you live or die so but if you won't have
something to say about it either way I
would love to have a a good back and
forth because that's what this is about
a community of conversation and
discourse and you know it's important to
see everybody's side but you know
craziness man craziness
another nut ball in the uh uh in the uh
in the in the in the world is Antonio
Brown
Antonio Brown the embattled receiver
from
the NFL who's like I think he got hit in
the head real bad when he was in
Pittsburgh like he took a vicious dirty
hit
in Pittsburgh and he's to me it feels
like he hasn't been the same but he was
out in Dubai at a hotel swimming in a
pool
and somebody caught a video of him
exposing himself
now
I the what what I really feel about it
is I like when video videos like this
come out because one who was recording
this video did he know the video was
being recorded like is it one of his
boys recording this and then look for a
chance that one of his boys I say quote
unquote
took this video and then leaked it and
sold it so he can make some money like
at what point because I think context
matters okay like I don't think listen
once something is filmed and it's put
out you have to answer for it okay I'm
not condoning him being in a public
setting with his monstrous dick out by
the way the way they blurted I was like
damn and little Antonio Brown is packing
right he packing that heat
but
I can't comment about everything before
this video was released because we don't
know all the information
it's like you see this video and it
seems as if he's messing around with
this girl and then they're in the pool
together and she gets kind of weirded
out and leaves
um
and he's naked like he was already naked
to me it's like when did they start
filming this did he jump in the pool
naked and everybody saw him naked uh did
he was he like in the pool with these
women and then he just took his pants
off and all of a sudden he's like yo
messing around and being weird and
creepy like we don't know you just see
this video and then we had to just
assume what we what happened but it
seems to me like it's like it looks to
me like he was already butt ass naked in
the pool and everybody in the pool knew
he was naked so if you don't want to be
around him Don't Go Near him because
he's naked I I just don't know so then
he doesn't get the benefit of the doubt
because of his crazy behavior from the
past he doesn't get the benefit of the
doubt but that it wasn't a bubble bath
and you walked over to him you saw this
mofo was naked so at that point I'm like
hey what's going on are we missing
they're not we're not seeing the whole
video are we are we missing out on some
fun that was going on that got out of
hand because that happens too it's all
fun and games until somebody goes I
don't like this anymore and that's fair
like I'm not blaming a girl either the
girl could have been like oh this is
cute he's naked and boom boom and then
he's in the pool and then all of a
sudden it's you know he gets erect and
then she's like whoa this is too much
and then she just decides to walk away
then it's like hey that's fair man what
are you doing right but what I'm saying
is this video they're just showing this
video and they're making them out to be
a great crazy person and by the way he
don't get the benefit of the doubt
because he's been crazy you know what
I'm saying oh so so somebody in the chat
saying he already responded and said the
woman stole his shorts
so this is what I'm saying like we don't
know all but you know we don't know what
was going on there like if they were
just messing around with each other you
know what I mean and but you see this
video and it seems as if
it seems as if oh he's this crude
whatever person and I'm saying hey we
didn't see the whole story that being
said no matter what version of the story
comes out you still have to answer for
that story so yeah
if you're presented in a way that you
look like uh indecent crazy person you
then have to come out and say something
about that which I believe he's doing
but I just want to read these funny ass
Antonio Brown cheat uh tweets man he got
some funny tweets man he goes every
chance they get to sway the heat of
themselves they use me in the video you
can clearly see she runs off with my
swim trunks It Roll if rolls were
reversed the headlines would read a b
having a wild night with nude female yet
when it's me it's automatically becomes
a hate crime that's exactly what I'm
saying
he goes it's crazy to me even after I
retire there is disinformation coming
out about me ironically during a time
when the NFL is getting heat for
allowing players to play with their
clearly concussed they've been using
black men as guinea pigs I'm this is my
favorite line I'm telling every team
that needs some offense to pick up a b
because he's showing he's shown that he
still has the ability to expose a d
[Laughter]
so that's what I'm saying man I think
that
I'm not I I think that he's being
unfairly portrayed in this situation
believe what you want you know I don't
know if the woman herself has come out
and said anything or not I don't know
what's going on but to me it looked as
if people were having fun in the pool
but that being said y'all even if you
having fun in the pool there's a point
where it could go like okay you've gone
too far we all have that you do you make
you're messing with your lady and you're
doing some stuff then you go she's like
okay too much it's all fun fun fun till
it's not you know what I mean so at that
point it's okay for her to be like okay
I stole these shorts it was all fun but
then he like you know he pulled out his
monstrous dick and then I was like whoa
you know what I mean so who knows but uh
shout out for a B for at least being
funny about it you know
I just thought that was uh some
craziness all right
um what else here's okay here's another
crazy story that I'm talking about and
I'm also talking about this on stage man
it's all of this
um
all of this backlash about
Little Mermaid okay The Little Mermaid
y'all like it's like the racist backlash
a Little Mermaid of of the ring and of
the of that show the ring rings is
exhausting extremely predictable all
right so
his I just want to say sometimes
you can't get past
the stupidity
because you can't get to the racism or
Prejudice or whatever Behavior because
it's so stupid
when you have to say the words
mermaids
don't exist
foreign
mermaids
aren't real
therefore
it doesn't matter
what
real life race they are
it doesn't matter
what like I can't even get to the idea
that this is Prejudice or racist
it's stupid
if you're a white person and you're
taking offense that the cartoon
character
of a little mermaid's
race has been changed for this live
action movie
I don't even want to get to your racism
your
[ __ ] stupid
full stop
like
what
listen
I get that this push for diversity
is distracting
but you know why it's distracting
because everything's been white for so
long that now when we see different
races we're kind of like whoa wait a
minute
uh this doesn't make sense it's only
because things have been white for so
long it doesn't matter we'll normalize
it we'll move on with our lives who
cares
but if you're really concerned about it
talking about like some of the things
people were saying in some of these
articles man some of the things people
are saying
like the original Little Mermaid is uh
like well I don't know who cares about
that tweet
um
I don't know man I I just I don't even
want to go into it it's just some of the
stuff people are saying
you know when you when you look at
people's like these like you know sort
of idiot people's tweets
look
if
they cast Samuel Jackson
as Abraham Lincoln then I'm with you
okay
because then I'm like what this isn't
factually correct you know I don't want
to see
four [ __ ] score then you'd be
like all right this is the diversity is
going too far
but when it's a fictional character from
a made-up fictional story
who cares
who cares
like I say guys
Full Stop on that
[Laughter]
all right guys uh uh let's talk some
Helix sleep one of our favorite uh
sponsors this episode's brought to you
by Helix sleep
um we I have a helix sleep mattress and
I'm not just saying it the sucker is
comfortable and they had this sleep quiz
that you can like get the stuff you want
for because usually you just say you
think a mattress is just a mattress
maybe is it soft or is it hard but
actually how you sleep your body type
all that stuff's important so Helix
sleep offers a great sleep quiz to help
you find out what's the best mattress
for you
healing sleep is a premium mattress
brand that provides tailored mattresses
based on your unique sleep preferences
that's what I'm talking about take the
Sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes it's like
Tinder for mattresses man you're gonna
swipe right on the proper mattress Helix
knows there's no better way to test out
a new mattress than sleeping on it
they're going to give you a hundred
nights a hundred night risk free and
then they'll pick it up for free full
refund they have great mattress
selections I'm a side sleeper but we're
gonna get a new one because now you know
Rachel's not a side sleeper so we're
gonna find some like medium in the
middle she's already filled out her new
sleep quiz and we're going to get
another Helix mattress
plus Helix mattresses are American made
and come with a 10 or 15 year warranty
and remember you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free Helix has been
awarded the number one mattress picked
by GQ and Wired Magazine Helix is
offering up to 200 of all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com slash
Griffin
also Georgia Dash
I love doordash we use doordash
um you know sometimes you're running
late you don't got time sometimes you go
to the store you buy some stuff but you
forgot a few items doordash is there for
you
um you know what do you want to eat
tonight maybe you want a home-cooked
favorite but you don't feel like going
back to the store or you know what I
mean then use doordash doordash is great
along with the restaurants you love you
can now get groceries and other
essential items deliver it with doordash
to get drinks snacks and other household
items in under an hour with over 300 000
Partners you can support your
neighborhood go to stores and
restaurants uh you know or you could
choose from National favorites like
Popeyes Chipotle or Cheesecake Factory
or like I say those ones those Mom Pop
places that are right down the street
from the stores and restaurants to to
Dashers driving around each purchase
provides a new opportunity for everyone
involved because doordash there's a
neighborhood of good in every order for
a limited time our listeners get 25 off
and zero delivery fees on their first
order of 15 or more when you download
the doordash app and enter code Griffin
that's 25 off up to ten dollar value and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code Griffin
don't forget that code Griffin for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
all right y'all
um thanks for being here guys thanks for
being here we're from Griffin we're just
look remember uh to subscribe uh be a
part of the magic all the time hit that
notification uh remember I'm on Twitch
I'm gonna be on Twitch after this that's
Eric Griffin gaming so come check that
out all right y'all let's get to uh
let's get to the reviews and spoilers
reviews this is the time right now I
want to I just want to go into the major
one that I wanted that I wanted to do
man because this
man
the Dahmer series man it's on Netflix
got a lot of feelings about it man a lot
of feelings about it
um
let me just go to the I just want to go
to the the thing
uh wait I'm sorry I didn't spell Netflix
right you know
someone's at the front door that's
probably Rachel at the front door so
first of all
it stars Evan Peters
um I don't know if you know who Evan
Peters is he's uh you know he's he's
been on a lot you if you saw him you'd
be like oh that guy right
um first of all I didn't recognize him
all right I didn't recognize him
let me tell you something right now
the first 30 minutes
of the pilot of Dahmer episode one the
first 30 minutes
is some of the creepiest television
I've ever watched in my life okay
just the art this just talk art all
right let's just talk art right now then
I'll talk about what other things I was
going to talk about
it's so well made in that way
you get a visceral reaction from
yourself when you watch this
it's so creepy the music they're doing
this
whatever the hell that is they're doing
creepy as hell
this guy Andy Evan Peters is playing
like like I said I didn't recognize him
for four episodes
it took me four episodes to be like and
see something on the Internet where I
was like oh wow he's playing Dahmer and
I was like man Dahmer's like it was like
six three this dude's like five seven so
the artistic of filming it to making him
seem like he was bigger it is just so
creepy they opened the series off with
like it's when he got caught right and
then they retell many of his light like
sort of his life story through the
victim's eyes and many times and through
his like uh neighbor which they sort of
combined two of The Neighbors in this
character because the person Nishi Niecy
Nash is playing a character Glenda
Cleveland who did not actually live next
door to Dahmer she lived across the
street from Dahmer but there was a woman
who lived in Dahmer's building who he
did try to give a sandwich to
um
this the series is like it's so it's
very well made
it's very creepy and it really does not
in a lot of ways some of these serial
killer things sort of glorify it and
sort of make it seem like oh this is
like you know you don't you get
desensitized to the horrors of what was
happening not this series man I felt
every little bit of it uh like not even
a fraction of you know to these victims
and their families who are still alive
the families are still alive and who
probably hated this series
um but man I tell you
this was some creepy [ __ ] man and it
really made you think about like I'm
just gonna tell you I made me feel I
that Dahmer was like
otherworldly psycho
the fact that he was in an apartment
building
with neighbors
and he was
killing sawing at at putting people in
acid chopping them up eating them in his
apartment
brazenly going to gay bars and bringing
people home and no one's looking for
these people you know there are some
that say
you know he moved to this particular
neighborhood on purpose because it was
underserved by the police
and then the the series sort of alluded
to that but at the same time May Dahmer
come across as like that's not why I did
it it was just cheap you know like I
don't know if he thought about it in
that way he was so crazy but just the
fact that he was so brazen and just
completely psycho and out of it
can you imagine I have neighbors just
imagine like you hearing muffled screams
or you hear him saw you're hearing you
know power tools
when the 14 year old kids sort of
escaped and then the cops brought him
back and and just like it really made me
feel uncomfortable and at first I was
like Ugh this serious but at the same
time I think
that's the point of it the point of it
is to make you feel uncomfortable and
really think like yo there are horrible
people out here like this all right so
the art of it great music great
directing great acting the Father the
dude playing the Father Richard Jenkins
the the guy that plays the father if you
see him you recognize he's like he's in
a lot of comedies too he's always
playing a funny dad
man this dude is doing a he did a great
job as the father
so those are the things I say I like
about the series is uh it really puts
you in a state of mind but I'll say this
man
why make this
like at a certain point you go
why do we need to still
use this for entertainment
like are they gonna make like are we
gonna say you know Hitler the young
years I mean that Series going to come
to CBS it'll be like young Sheldon and
then young Hitler like you know there's
there's a reason why you don't see a lot
of Hitler movies TV shows
uh you know it's because it was so
horrible it's like nah maybe we don't
make money off this
I I don't know
I just I just feel like there is a part
of me that's like
I don't know if this was necessary
the artist in me is like great job well
done you really made people feel
something the other part of me is like I
don't know if this was necessary and
there are some things I didn't like
about it like
they really put the narrative out there
through the series that it was the mom's
fault
I don't know what you guys think about
it but tell me what you think
like was they they they they they put
this narrative out there that like the
mom
um you know because she was a drug user
because she was depressed because she
was like you know she she wasn't all
there because she sort of left him you
know
she like left him when he was like 17 18
years old and like all right fend for
yourself
I don't know why sorry about this I
I was like I got a gummy out and then I
realized uh eating gummies is all out
so they you know and then also the
that's why I think the guy playing the
father
he really portrayed like a father who
blames himself and it's like oh my God
is this my fault I didn't do enough
so they so they portrayed the father as
taken like responsibility for this but
they portrayed the mom as like this
devil man
and I didn't I didn't like that part of
it
um you know there's a lot of backlash in
the series you know Dahmer was he gay or
not I you know they there was a lot of
like you know gay LGBT whatever you
whatever the term is but it was gay men
a lot of gay stuff and so they had the
LGBT you know thing on it like hey but
then did that the community got so upset
like no as if there aren't horrible gay
people you know what I'm saying
you know it's like what it's like you
know it it's like every show that has
like a caddy gay guy on it who's like
you know you know who's like mean like
they you know you know what I mean like
listen there's good and bad people of
all walks of life
I don't think they should have taken it
off but I get why I mean at the same
time though I'm not I'm not mad at it I
think if they're saying hey we don't
really we get enough heat we get enough
backlash can we not have gay associated
with Dahmer you know what I mean so I
get it all right
I'm not I I don't I don't I didn't like
it but I get it a hundred percent okay
uh uh you know so I didn't like that and
then I didn't like I didn't like I
didn't like the response from like the
police who were trying to say like they
were portrayed as not caring about black
people or gays in this neighborhood and
I thought
like the police
I think like just shut up don't even
bring attention to yourself in this way
I mean police brutality and stuff has
been going on
since before Jeffrey Dahmer during
Jeffrey Dahmer it's like it was a shock
oh that the cops didn't care about the
black neighborhood like oh my God does
that sound like a shocker to you it's
like the guys just I think they
shouldn't have even responded no one
should have said anything they should
have just like let this go when this
series is over No One's Gonna care and
they're gonna move on with their lives
but bringing attention to that but at
the same time I will say this
you know they had this sort of
Indonesian comp family I'm not even sure
if they're Indonesia but they were
obviously like something like that of
the kid that got killed in in real life
and they and they had it that they were
getting hate calls you know and in the
series
they made it out like it was the cops
that were doing the hate calls and I was
trying to Google if that was true like
did they find out definitively that it
was the cops doing that personally I
don't think they should have done that
they don't they shouldn't have portrayed
that it was already bad enough that
you know these cops sort of like saw
that this kid who you know was
disoriented and he was like an indomer
comes out with his like Smooth talk like
oh this is my boyfriend and he just got
drunk and it's like I mean you kind of
go what would you do in that situation
like after watching the Dahmer series if
you're a cop and you see a gay dude
passed out you're gonna be like yo all
right we need to see some ID and we need
to check on this and make sure this is
real but before that I mean I'm not
condoning it I'm just saying that's a
tough spot to be in you know
and then but it's like
those cops they messed up man they
messed up like they completely messed up
you know uh and I think if they had to
do it again who knows because who knows
if like you know this is what I'm saying
it's so much anti-police sentiment out
there that I don't think they should
have portrayed it
in that way you know they really
portrayed the cops as beans just like
completely callous and uncaring and I
know that's not the case it's not every
cop man that hates people it's not you
know what I'm saying it's not every cop
it's not every you know it's like you
know they got put in the situation it
reminds me of the Tua tavolo of uh
concussion Doctor Who just recently got
fired in that moment he made a call that
was wrong and they fired him or maybe it
wasn't wrong maybe he did think it was
the guy's back who knows in this
situation same kind of thing these cops
made a bad call and they probably should
have been fired at the time but who
knows but anyways my point is
that all the things that they portrayed
in this series really made you like man
it it made me it made me so
uncomfortable and it didn't glorify this
at all in my opinion
um and so I do give this show it's worth
watching
if you're into this sort of thing but if
you want to feel some stuff like that I
would say watch it but if you don't if
you're like ah I'm good on this I
totally understand that too but man I'll
tell you it was something y'all the
Dahmer series was something
you know and it's like again you know I
see someone saying this is a part of
history people always find ways to
cancel the truth I mean we just don't
know what the truth is that's the thing
too it sucks you know because even when
you watch in a documentary about stuff
um
you you start you now we know we get a
sense that this is a narrative being
pushed who made this documentary like
what facts did they put in and leave out
it's like making a murderer man remember
that big series making a murderer and
like we were like outraged as a
community just being like I can't
believe that guy's in prison
but then you come to find out later that
they left out a lot of information and
they put forth a narrative that this guy
was probably innocent and you know you
know and so my thing is like give me all
the facts and information that's what a
documentary should be that at the end we
can make our own determination but when
you when it comes to entertainment
series and when it comes to documentary
it's up to the Creator they're putting
their narrative forward and in this one
the producers of the Dahmer series for
sure put their narrative forward or the
mom was it was the mom's fault
uh you know the cops were terrible
and you know
Jeffrey Dahmer was just straight up
crazy
you know and he was and he and he wasn't
even targeting like they they put up
they made it seem like Jeffrey Dahmer
was just crazy and he wasn't targeting
black people because they were black uh
he wasn't living in that black
neighborhood because it was a black
neighborhood that he was trying to get
away from the cops you know they had
their own narrative I don't know if
that's true or not but I'm saying is
they pushed that narrative forward so
again I say watch it let me know what
you think about it and you know we'll
have a discussion in the chat
all right
um okay there's Dahmer y'all
um
um now let's get back into
[Music]
um I just want to briefly talk about
some other shows that you did you know I
watched and continue to watch
um She-Hulk y'all I don't like it y'all
I'm just I now that I've seen all these
episodes I don't like it collectively as
a series I think it's too disjointed the
story doesn't flow
but I will say this the last episode I
just saw was really great it was this
sort of like group therapy episode and
it was a great Standalone episode like
it was a great it was the people in it
were funny I thought it was well
directed it was well written and the
performances were great and at the end
of that episode they should have they
sort of indicate that hey we're now
getting to a real story of what's
happening but up to this point that I
feel like that Titania girl that
storyline I just that's the useless
storyline you know she's a dad it's not
a good villain uh you know you're just
trying to find out what is this about
what's happening and it's just I don't
think they're doing a very good job of
that but it's surrounded by great
special effects and the the lead actress
is fantastic she does a great great job
so the last episode I like I said this
group therapy episode I thought was
really good but overall as a series I'm
just kind of uh on it you know I'm like
what is this about like what are we what
are we uh
that nothing's happening man
uh I see somebody talk about Andor I
started watching that and I'm gonna talk
about that the next time I do a solo I'm
gonna watch more episodes but so far so
good with that one but she Hulk
kind of like on it you know now let's
get the house of dragons y'all
House of the Dragon I think is what
isn't that what it's called
uh House of the drug I always say House
of dragons but that's not what it is
it's House of the Dragon
it's fine it's heating up man
you know I feel like it is finally
heating up
um
[Music]
okay so they're doing a lot of time
jumps so I didn't like the time jump in
the first four episodes where it went
from you know the king got what his
daughter's best friend and then cut two
they got three kids okay
I didn't necessarily like that time Jump
[Music]
um
because it was like sort of the same
cast right and then like now cut two
they made a significant time Jump like
10 years later or something and now the
daughter is like you know she's a grown
woman and you know the queen is like you
know she's now like feeling herself you
know what I mean and now this the
stories it's now Heating and now it
feels like uh it feels like Game of
Thrones now
it really feels like Game of Thrones I
don't think enough people have been
murdered uh unceremoniously you know
what I mean like I don't think enough
there's not enough like uh you know
unnecessary deaths in it
weird thing to talk about after talking
about the Dahmer series but this is all
the make-believe portion
and you know what I mean like even
spoiler you know
what's her name
um
the name the names are too close man you
know what I'm saying like the king's
name is you know I just sometimes I just
don't I don't like to I don't like the
names dude
so you got
um yeah so Miley I'll cook
princess Raina whatever her name is
right what is her name princess
you know princess is that how you say it
princess
ranaris or whatever her name is all
those game of thronesy names
you know what I mean like she then you
got like Olivia Cook playing Queen
Allison like so so Olivia Cook now she's
the adult version of the queen she's
great you know she's turned into an evil
[ __ ] I like her and then all right yeah
so there was then Emma Darcy
yeah she's playing princess renara
renaria whatever her name is
Targaryen and and then like so now
remember she had a little thing with her
Uncle so now her and her uncle in
cahoots like they some some crazy stuff
goes on there you know the Targaryen is
all about incest so they got some pure
blood stuff going on there but here's
the thing though I don't want to spoil
it for you but
you think they make a game of Game of
Thrones decision
and then it turns out they sort of
didn't
and so I didn't know how I felt about
that if you all know what I'm talking
about you know what I'm talking about
from the last episode but I do like that
the Intrigue is um um filling in and
it's like who's the evil people here you
know
it's like you know you got the the the
black blonde family so the black blonde
Family the son who's gay is with the
princess they was trying to have kids
obviously it didn't work out so she was
having sex with like you know one of the
uh one of the nights whatever she had
three kids two or three kids with him
and they clearly looked like him that's
the thing that that's weird about it to
me it's like I would be on the page of
everybody being like everybody knows
that's not our kid this dude's kids the
dude's black with blonde hair and none
of the kids are black with blonde hair
it's kind of like did you really think
he was gonna get away with this it's
like you know what I mean like that's
the part of it that that's how Brazen
she is so
you know that the targaryens are evil
because we know how to uh Game of
Thrones so it's just trying to figure
out like how evil are they like like
this is their checkered past and why
they so now we're start I'm interested
again I'm sort of interested even though
I know where it's going to go later down
the line because we've seen uh Game of
Thrones it's interesting to see like
well damn what happened to the dragons
you know oh and it was like in the kids
the kids are evil like it's like
everybody in this show is terrible you
know I can't I don't know who the good
guy is in this show and I like that
because I don't want to root for none of
them so that means anybody could die at
any time
so
um
I do I do uh I do like it now I mean I I
was already I was iffy on it if you
remember some of my last reviews but now
that like it's a more like the people
that were sort of younger are now adults
and they're dealing with who's gonna sit
on the Iron Throne which is like a thing
that that's gonna be a common thing that
goes on in this but that that's what
goes on with this kind of stuff who's
gonna sit on the Iron Throne so I do
like it uh I I I it's I'm enjoying it
and I will continue to talk about it and
so we will see where it goes from there
all right y'all
um
I want to shout out to everybody that
you know if you send me
all the people that have been sending me
Beats
for you know the end the end the end rap
and uh you know the the the
rap recap you know you can still send
beats you can email me at
ericgirlfriend.com and my man fishy who
sends beats like the day of he sent me
this one but I want to thank everybody
for watching riffin with Griffin all
right make sure you subscribe
make sure you hit me up on Twitch and
remember patreon doing some Rachel stuff
there
all right so yeah everybody
one of these fishing Beats
[Music]
while we look back
oh everything is
[Music]
everybody think he a clown
[Music]
in the pool
almost drowned
she Hawkins
[Music]
all right
that's all we got from that fishy beat
on the rap recap but you know what guys
uh I appreciate you guys being here uh
you can always send me something and
I'll be on Twitch shortly but thanks for
watching riffin with Griffin and I will
see you next week
hmm
let's see let's hear that fishy beat
again right where is it here it is
[Music]